[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le poète gustave nadaud a dit rester
c'est exister et voyager c'est vivre
donc si je comprends bien ce qui voulait
dire elle même est un voyage waouh c'est
vraiment très profond et en même temps
très poétique
je pense également à ce que disait le
philosophe jean d'ormesson qui disait
que la vie est un voyage en train
je ne sais pas vous mais moi dans ma
jeunesse j'ai beaucoup pris le train les
trains régionaux le tgv les trains
grandes lignes
les trains de nuit les trains wagons les
trains couchettes et dans les trains
comme mon avis nous faisons beaucoup de
rencontres des rencontres fortuites des
rencontres accidentelle des rencontres
occasionnelles des rencontres régulières
des rencontres fréquentes et des fois
nous développons des relations et comme
dans les trains dans la vie les gens
vont rentrer dans votre vie et vont
sortir et des fois vous allez rentrer
dans la vie de certaines personnes et
vous allez en décembre ce sont comme on
dit fait moins les choses de la vie et
donc de par mes voyages j'ai l'occasion
de d'aller dans différents pays
j'ai eu l'occasion d'apprendre beaucoup
de langues et comme disait le philosophe
descartes il disait cette phrase célèbre
que nous connaissons tous cogito ergo
soum
je pense donc je suis moi j'ai ma phrase
à moi je voyage
donc je suis et c'est vrai qu'il ya
plusieurs types de voyages compte en
parle de voyage c'est vrai que je vous
ai parlé très rapidement de mes voyages
et de mex de mes expériences en train
mais il ya plusieurs types de voyages et
le premier type de voyage c'est ce que
moi j'appelle un déplacement physique ou
un déplacement géographique par exemple
quand vous prenez l'avion où vous prenez
le train ou le bateau où le bus c'est le
voyage le plus commun et quand on parle
de voyage
je veux vous dire que moi je suis un
privilégié
je sais que c'est dangereux de dire ça
mais c'est la vérité j'ai commencé à
voyager très jeune j'ai fait mon premier
voyage à l'âge de un an avec ma famille
donc nous sommes allés à new york et j'y
ai passé les six années suivantes de ma
vie c'est j'appelle ça new york la
grosse pomme des big apple et j'appelle
new york la ville de mon enfance je me
souviens du lycée français de new york
je me souviens de mon terrain de jeu
préféré
central park mon playground comme ils
disent je me souviens des tours jumelles
à l'époque où elle existe est
malheureusement et je me souviens de cet
épisode dans l'empiré state building où
je me suis perdue pendant plusieurs
heures
mais mr ne savais pas où j'étais mais
gégé été retrouvé et je pense également
à au sud de la france que j'aime
beaucoup je pense à aix en provence la
ville de paul cézanne je pense aux cours
mirabeau
je pense à marseille la ville phocéenne
et son vieux port et le prado et la gare
saint-charles et je pense également à ma
famille de coeur les berthier je pense à
ce rêve de gosse aller en egypte
je me souviens quand j'étais gamin je
lisais les bd et je me souviens avoir lu
tintin qui allait en egypte avec le
capitaine haddock sais pas si vous vous
souvenez
et c'était un rêve pour moi et j'ai
réalisé ce rêve et comme tintin je suis
allé dans les tombeaux des pharaons
j'ai été à dos de chameau dans le désert
déguisé j'ai été au pied des pyramides
extraordinaire akhenaton khéops j'ai été
devant le sphinx
j'ai été dans la ville historique la
ville historique de saqqarah et j'ai été
dans la capitale
l'ancienne capitale d'égypte memphis une
expérience extraordinaire
je pense aussi et je ne veux pas oublier
embrun magie l'adolescence dans les
hautes-alpes dans la montagne
et je pense à je considère que c'est ma
ville d'adolescence et je pense à ma
famille d'accueil les bakayoko je pense
à ma maman de coeur geneviève et je
pense à toutes ces familles qui m'ont
ouvert leur coeur qui m'ont ouvert leur
maison je pense aux baronnies je pense
aux berthier je pense aux à sa fin et
beaucoup d'autres et je pense également
à cette expérience extraordinaire que
j'ai fait avec un de mes amis on a pris
un bain à 26 degrés en montagne à 1000
mètres dans le plan de phazy ou la
source de phase i se baigner en plein de
montagne la nature c'est une expérience
extraordinaire
je pense également à mon pays natal mon
pays de coeur
le gabon je pense à ma ville de
naissance libreville
je pense à mme je pense à la ville de
lambaréné alain barré ni la ville ou à
maman et est enterré ville connue grâce
à son hôpital l'hôpital du docteur
schweitzer ou passe au bord du fleuve
ogooué le plus grand fleuve d'abonnés je
pense au village de ma maman abondé sim
à jérusalem un lieu extraordinaire et
magique en pleine forêt équatoriale
je pense que c'est l'un des endroits les
plus extraordinaires avec l'afrique la
forêt d'amazon je pense à aux parties de
chasse aux parties de pêche avec mes
cousins
je pense aux balades dans la nature dans
la forêt je pense aux arbres géants
on se croirait en plein new york sauf
que c'est pas des buildings ce sont des
arbres qui touche les cieux et j'entends
et je vois les singes qui sautent
d'arbre en arbre
vous savez les singes dans la forêt ce
sont les donneurs d' alerte c'est qu'ils
avertissent mais attention il ya des
hommes et je pense à aux éléphants
qu'ils mangeaient les plantations de ma
maman et la nuit des éléphants qui sont
très intelligents et donc ma maman se
lever le matin elle était toujours en
colère contre les éléphants mais leur a
jamais fait de mal et donc il ya un
proverbe touareg qui dit que voyager ça
allait de soi en soit en passant par les
autres je pense que c'est vraiment très
très profonds et poétiques donc voyager
ce n'est pas seulement aller à la
rencontre de l'autre même si c'est
important ce n'est pas seulement
découvrir de nouveaux paysages
même si c'est super aller à la rencontre
de nouvelles contrées mais voyager je
pense que c'est surtout essentiellement
la découverte de soi même aussi est le
deuxième type de voyage dont je vous
parlais c'est ce que moi j'appelle le
voyage spirituel ou le voyage
initiatique
je pense par exemple à la culture
chamanique des indiens d'amérique où le
chaman à cette fonction à sept saulx
rôle spirituel de leader de sages qui
guide la communauté à travers sa
relation qu'il a avec les ancêtres et le
monde de l'au delà
d'ailleurs de plus en plus la culture
chamanique est exportée en europe et de
plus et pistes de de chaman européen et
je pense par exemple à mon pays à
nouveau le gabon et je pense par exemple
aux cérémonies traditionnelles du bwiti
qui ce qui est une intime de rite
initiatique qui a été créée par les
pygmées du gabon et donc où la
consommation de l'iboga qui est une qui
est une plante un arbuste est donc
l'iboga va faciliter le voyage spirituel
quand j'étais gamin on appelait ça un
voyage astral on disait tu va voyager
aller dans le monde de l'au-delà
rencontrer les ancêtres et pour moi
c'est très important parce que la
spiritualité surtout dans les temps dans
lesquels on vit on vit des moments
difficiles en général et surtout
maintenant avec la pandémie avec toutes
les difficultés
la spiritualité à à son rôle toutes les
formes de spiritualité
sont valables à mon sens ainsi que
toutes les religions
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup et
malheureusement et à raison d des
malades du corps vide qui qui sont en
réanimation ou bien des personnes qui
sont malheureusement décédés mais à mon
sens on parle peu de la souffrance
humaine on parle peu des problèmes de
santé mentale
on parle peu de l'isolément de la
solitude
on parle peu de la violence conjugale
qui augmente et des divorces qui ont
augmenté je pense que ce sont des choses
dont on parle peu malheureusement le
suicide chez les jeunes ont augmenté et
je pense que la spiritualité à sa place
à un rôle pour nous fortifier nous
rendre plus forts dans cette période que
nous livrons qui est vraiment difficile
et le troisième type de voyage à mon
sens ce qui est important c'est ce que
moi j'appelle le voyage mental entre
longtemps j'ai été ce que j'appelle un
non lecteur parce que j'estimais que
j'ai assez de connaissances je suis
quelqu'un de cultivé et pas besoin de
lire évidemment j'avais tort et la vie
et les circonstances de la vie ont fait
en sorte que je commence à lire et mark
twain à cette phrase qui m'a terrorisée
pendant longtemps il disait celui qui ne
lit pas n'a aucun avantage sur celui qui
ne sait pas lire
en d'autres termes ce que mark twain
voulait dire si tu ne lis pas tu ne sais
pas plus de choses que quelqu'un qui est
illettrée ou analphabètes et ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a vraiment fait mal
et j'ai commencé à lire et il ya trois
livres trois voyages qui m'ont vraiment
inspiré et le premier voyage c'est un
livre qui a été écrit par le docteur
norman vincent pile ce livre s'appelle
la puissance de la pensée positive
j'ai commencé à lire ce livre là dans
une peur de ma vie qui était difficile
j'étais malade j'étais malade
physiquement
évidemment j'étais malade psychologique
voix et je pense pis rituellement
et ce livre m'a donné de l'espoir ce
livre m'a donné de la force
ce livre m'a montré à travers ce voyage
que tu peux t'en sortir que c'est
possible et je m'en suis sorti et je
remercie énormément ce voyage à saint
nic dumas beaucoup aidé le deuxième
livre le deuxième voyage c'est un livre
qui s'appelle le plus grand vendeur du
monde qui a été écrit par augment dino
dans les années 70 au contraire de son
titre ce n'est pas un livre qui parle de
vente ou c'est pas un livre pour
commerciaux mais c'est un livre en fête
qui parle de la recherche du bonheur de
la recherche de l'épanouissement
c'est un livre vraiment très
intéressante qui m'a beaucoup aidé c'est
un voyage très important dans ma vie le
3 le troisième livre que dont je veux
parler c'est un livre qui a été écrit
par le docteur viktor frankl ce livre
s'intitule découvrir un sens à sa vie et
le docteur michel frenkiel c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai toujours beaucoup
admiré et quand j'ai commencé à lire ce
livre
j'étais à une période de ma vie qu'on
peut appeler je crois à la crise de la
quarantaine
et vous que je me posais énormément de
questions qui est-ce qui suis-je où est
ce que je vais qu'est ce que je veux
faire de ma vie
quel est le bilan de ma vie et ce livre
découvrir un sens à ma vie c'est un
livre tellement profond qui m'a amené
dans une introspection qui a duré six
ans mais à la fin de ces six années j'ai
trouvé un sens à ma vie
donc c'est un livre qui m'a apporté un
bénéfice incroyable est ce que je peux
vous dire pour pour conclure c'est que
nous vivons des temps très difficiles
nous vivons des périodes une période
d'incertitude
personne ne sait ce qui va arriver
demain entre les confinements les
restrictions donc on vit dans une
période où nous avons besoin de
travailler sur nous il ya un proverbe
que j'aime beaucoup et un proverbe que
j'aime beaucoup qui dit
si jeunesse savait et si vieillesse
pouvait l'auteur charles bukowski que
j'aime beaucoup il a sa version à lui il
dit dans la vie très souvent on fait les
choses trop tard et c'est justement le
problème que beaucoup de beaucoup
d'entre nous avons c'est vrai qu'il ya
toutes ces situations qui a en ce moment
mais souvent on remet les choses à trop
tard parce que et j'estime c'est mon
opinion personnelle qu'ont à 7
cette arrogance nous pensons que nous
sommes les maîtres des horloges et les
maîtres du temps alors on dit or on
remet les choses à demain je ferai les
choses plus tard plus tard quand j'aurai
de l'argent plus tard quand j'aurai mon
diplôme
plus tard quand les enfants seront
grands plus tard quand je serai en
retraite plus tard quand ce sera le bon
moment
plus tard plus tard et plus tard mais
malheureusement très souvent plus tard
devient trop tard et trop tard ne vient
jamais donc si je peux vous exhortez
aujourd'hui c'est à faire les choses
quand vous pouvez c'est vrai que si le
coc vide nous a appris quelque chose
c'est que la vie est précieuse et la vie
est fragile
donc je je je souhaite que vous puissiez
voyager c'est mon souhait pour vous
voltaire avait sept avaient cette phrase
fabuleuse il disait dieu nous a donnée
le vivre ça à nous deux nous donner le
bien vivre pour moi ça veut dire que ma
vie c'est ma responsabilité et vauvy
c'est vos responsabilités et si un jour
vous me croisez dans un de mes voyages
parce que je souhaite aller par exemple
en colombie cet été si vous ne croisez
dans un de mes voyages que ce soit dans
un aéroport ou dans une station tgv ou à
l'arrêt d'un bus
si vous ne croisez quelque part ça me
ferait énormément plaisir que vous me
disiez bonjour vous savez ma mère
c'était une femme bantou
elle avait un dicton qu'elle dise
qu'elle disait souvent de la discussion
jaillit la lumière et j'ai appris ça
d'elle et je n'ajouterai plus à ce que
maman disait évidemment maman avait
raison les mamans ont toujours raison
mais moi ce que je dis aussi c'est que
des discussions j'haïs les grandes
amitiés et les belles histoires d'amour
et donc pour conclure ce que je peux
vous souhaitez c c'est un bon voyage et
une vie remplie de découvertes et
laventure merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]